yesterday we were having it wasn't an
opening ceremony as much it was a
meeting of the players as well as the
drawing of lots and we have some shots
from yesterday's opening ceremony I must
say the players were very very friendly
to one another's like everybody had a
story that they wanted to tell of their
most recent outings it was a very
pleasant yeah off the board they're all
friends it's only at the board when they
become Fighters there we see Joy Bray by
the way welcoming the players very
beautiful
necklaces and bracelets uh drawing of
the Lots the numbers were on the other
side I was very very tempted to
take a look at the numbers uh yes sir
did you get your necklace as well no no
I missed out there was only 10 of them
and I felt very
unhappy that I I couldn't I couldn't
snack one I meant that I got extras no
way I'm going to talk to my agent this
is extremely unfair very